-We here at "Late Night"
don't always have enough time
to cover all of the recent news.
So here with the recap
is one of our writers,
Amber Ruffin, in a segment
we call "Amber Says What."
♪♪
-Hey! You guys,
things have been crazy.
Okay, first of all, I heard
that Amy Robach and T.J. Holmes
from "Good Morning America"
were having an affair,
and I was like, what?
Then I read that they got
kicked off the show
and I was like, what?
Then I heard that their exes
are dating each other,
and I was like, what...
is "Good Morning America" doing?
Let all four of them
host together
and give us the chaos
we deserve!
Make that show
last 24 hours long,
bring in a couples counselor,
and let the Emmys roll in, baby.
Then I saw that Beyoncé went to
the opening of
Taylor Swift's movie
and I was like, what?
Why?
[ Laughter ]
Taylor is no Beyoncé.
Then I saw that Taylor went to
Beyoncé's movie
and I was like, what?
Then I read that they went
to each other's openings
because people are always
pitting them against each other
and they're sick of it,
so I was like, what?
I've been doing that.
And then I vowed to stop.
So then I read Taylor Swift
was named
"Time's" Person of the Year,
and I was like...
...what...
a lovely choice.
Then I saw the Rockefeller
Center Christmas tree
arrived and I was like --
[ To the tune of
"O Christmas Tree" ]
♪ What, what, what,
what, what, what, what ♪
♪ What, what, what, what,
what, what, what ♪
Oh, geez,
beautiful, loves attention,
and as always at 30 Rock.
Who are you, me?
Then I read everybody
was furious
because Chris Wallace
told Adam Driver
he was ugly in an interview.
And I was like, what?
So turns out,
Chris Wallace was like,
"You don't look like
the typical movie star.
And would your career be better
if you were better looking?"
And I was like,
this is what happens
when you let older white men
talk to young people.
Look, watch this.
Hey, Seth, what did you say
when you met my niece?
-Oh,
"Do you like Matchbox 20?"
-See? A bunch of mess.
What does that even mean?
Then I saw George Santos
joined Cameo,
and I was like, what?!
My favorite messy diva,
George Santos, is on Cameo?
What a perfect Christmas gift.
So I bought us
all a little Cameo from him.
-Hey, it's me, George Santos.
Don't be giving me any money.
If you do, I'll probably just
use it to steal another baby.
Then that's on you.
This is definitely me,
George Santos.
George Santos play video games,
right?
-Then I heard Brenda Lee
recently celebrated
that her song "Rockin' Around
the Christmas Tree"
made it to the top
of the Billboard 100
for the first time since 1958,
and I was like, what?
Then I found out she was only 13
when she recorded it,
and I was like,
what does a 13-year-old know
about rockin' around
the Christmas tree?
Girl, you better have a seat.
You're not old enough
to be rocking around
the nothing
with your lil' fast tail.
Then during a town hall,
Trump was asked
if he got elected,
was he going to be a dictator?
And Trump replied,
"Only on day one."
And I was like, what?
The correct answer was "no,"
unless you're asking me
that question,
then the answer is "yes."
The citizens of Ruffinland
are required
to give me little kisses,
fear and applaud me, or else.
[Bleep], you would love
to live there.
You would never leave.
Then I heard that
it's Seth's birthday soon
and I was like, what?
Then I heard he was turning 50
and I was like...
what?!
Because I assume his hearing
is starting to go.
Seth, if you can hear me,
say Amber is the most beautiful
and talented writer I ever met,
and we should trade salaries...
-I'm not saying that.
-He can't hear.
[ Laughter ]
Then I read that FSU
was left out of
the college football playoffs
even though they
were undefeated.
And I was like, what?
This really affects me, because
I think those players at...
I want to say
Florida State University?
-Yeah, that's right.
-Worked really hard to win...
like somewhere
between 10 and 15 games?
-Yeah, right again.
-Yes.
And they should
be commended for that!
So you gotta blame
the head of football...
Dan Marino?
-No. What?
-Shut up. I did my best.
Then the White House
delayed its ban
on menthol cigarettes
over concerns
that it will hurt Biden's
popularity with Black voters.
And I was like, what?
The nerve!
How dare you be so loud
and so right?
Then the Oxford Dictionary
named the slang word "rizz"
as the word of the year.
It means having style,
charm or attractiveness.
Seth, you got any rizz?
-Shoot, this Rizz God
is slinging
these interviews on the daily.
-Oh, dang!
Maybe Seth does have rizz.
-I mean, not as much rizz
as Matchbox 20, but --
-Never mind.
Guys, this has been
"Amber Says What."
♪♪
-Amber Ruffin, everybody!
We'll be right back
with Kate McKinnon!